I don't feel any you know any pressure
to rush the situation I mean this is an
important contract for dak it's an
important contract for our organization
we have to get it right and I feel like
we'll do that Steven Jones Cowboys CEO
regarding one of the biggest items of
business pending for the Cowboys what to
do with dak Prescott you know Sherine
earlier this week he he mentioned that
Aaron Rodgers with his thirty three and
a half million dollar contract and
Russell Wilson now with 35 million
they've won Super Bowls kind of a little
backhanded slap at dak for not winning
one but I don't know that that's a range
that I don't think anybody's trying to
put dak in in my assessment he's
somewhere between 25 and 30 million a
year once they do this contract is that
what the Cowboys are looking at is that
what Dax looking at are they going to be
able to find a consensus as to what the
right number is for this guy yeah that
is the biggest question how much does he
actually want and how much of the
Cowboys actually willing to pay I mean
Stephen Jones is mentioned on multiple
occasions that this has to be a team
friendly deal what is a team friendly
deal but I think you're right it's got
to be in that 25 to 30 million dollar
range he's not gonna become the
highest-paid player and football if he
wants that they're probably willing to
let him walk away because they don't
believe that's who he is
but they do believe that he is their
franchise quarterback they can win with
him and they have won with him frankly
he's never had a losing record in the
NFL so he does have something for that
but again they haven't been to the
championship game even the championship
game since 1995 so you know Tony Romo
didn't take them there and they're
hoping dak Prescott can take them there
but he hasn't yet hasn't been passed the
divisional round when you say that they
would let him walk away the question
from my perspective becomes when that
decision would be made would it be made
after his rookie contract expires
following this season would it be after
one year of the franchise tag or two
years of the franchise tag like
Washington did with Kirk Cousins when's
the moment where they would say enough
we're just gonna go find a new
quarterback
yeah I think you're right I think it
would be a Kirk Cousins situation if
they can't get him signed to a long-term
deal they franchise him and then they
probably franchise him again and then
he's going to walk away and go somewhere
else and you know I I the Cowboys have
never let's let's put this way the
Cowboys when they want to keep somebody
they've always managed to keep somebody
they have never let anyone walk out the
door that they have wanted to keep ever
in the Jerry Jones tenure which dates
back to 1989 so if they want to keep
that dak Prescott they are going to get
a deal done with that Prescott there is
no question in my mind about that is
there inherent value in being the Dallas
Cowboys quarterback for your full career
10-15 years does that I mean I know one
he's already got endorsement deals that
he probably wouldn't have if he was
playing for most other teams but look at
the revolving door of of former Cowboys
into broadcast booths I mean I do think
there is some value there I don't know
how you quantify it for the purposes of
doing a contract now but I think there's
real value to dak Prescott in being the
Cowboys quarterback versus being someone
else's quarterback that you need to
factor in at some point when you're
talking about the difference between a
million dollars here and a million
dollars there per year on a long-term
contract well you're also talking about
no state income tax we're going to throw
that in there so that makes a big
difference too but you're right he makes
more in endorsements right now than he
does on his actual contract and I don't
mean just a little bit more he makes a
lot more having been a fourth round
draft pick and he wouldn't have those
endorsements that you as you said if he
was in Jacksonville if he was somewhere
else in a lower market team Arizona
whatever he has those endorsements
because he is in Dallas and I do think
that factors in and the Cowboys want to
get a deal done with him and him wanting
to get a deal done with the Cowboys at
maybe a little less than he would take
somewhere else let the record reflect
that I tried to be very diplomatic and
not name any of the other lesser cities
Sherine went there though with
Jacksonville in Arizona so send the
emails to her not me
Shareen NFL on Twitter Jaguars and
Cardinals fans but but it's reality it's
and it's most teams that fall into that
category
when you are the Cowboys starting
quarterback you have an extra level of
cachet that you otherwise wouldn't have
how do you turn that into a long-term
contract and and where is dak Prescott
mindset from that perspective he's
always said he wants a fair contract
Chris Sims did an interview with him at
the Super Bowl and Chris Sims threw out
this idea that all you know he'd do a
tempura team friendly deal and Dec gave
him the side I liked don't negotiate on
my behalf Chris so you know this is
gonna be a challenge for the Cowboys and
if it's franchise tag it's gonna be more
than 25 million next year 2020 which
means there'll be more than 30 million
in 2021 and then you're looking at that
44 percent raise by rule that would
almost guarantee that he would hit the
open market and you know we talked about
this earlier on the TV side only as it
relates to today being clowny the Texans
linebacker maybe at some point you just
have to let a guy go to the market and
see what else is out there or what else
isn't out there cause Sharina as much as
the Cowboys don't want to pay him more
than 30 million a year if he was a free
agent right now I can't think of another
team that would pay him more than 30
million a year yeah I agree with you and
it is common also mike was interesting
that he made about Gisele when he said
they said Tom Brady has a team friendly
deal what is Tom now the 20th
highest-paid quarterback or whatever he
has he's way down the list and any
indexes that's great except his wife
makes more than Tom Brady makes so he is
not willing to go at a certain level
it's just a question of exactly what
that level is and if he wants to be the
highest-paid quarterback in the NFL
which is the highest paid player in the
NFL the Cowboys aren't going to go for
that there's no question about that so
what is that middle ground and as you
said you base it on what the franchise
tags are over the next two years I
wonder at some point whether or not
they're gonna put him in a room with
Tony Romo because Rome will always took
less than if he never drove a hard
bargain and my theory was look the guy
was undrafted he was just happy to be
here and whatever he got was millions
and millions more than he ever thought
he was gonna get in the NFL but you know
maybe he needs to hear it from somebody
who's been there and done that as to
what the value is of being the Cowboys
quarterback because now Romo is going to
be making 10 million a year eventually
just to call games and that's the
foundation you lay by being the Cowboys
starting quarterback so I feel like
they're gonna work it out but it's not
going to be as smooth as they want it to
be Shireen no it's not and this is going
to go a while and I don't think it's
going to get done anytime soon as you
said you need a deadline
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports